>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THERE IS A NOT SO THEORETICAL
QUESTION, WHEN IS IT OKAY TO PAY
OFF FEMALE ACCUSERS?
NBC NEWS HAS HAD NO PROBLEM
DOING IT OVER THE YEARS ON
BEHALF OF GRABBY TV ANCHORS, BUT
NOW THAT DONALD TRUMP IS ACCUSED
OF DOING IT, NBC TELL US THAT IS
A FELONY.
HOW EXACTLY DOES THAT WORK?
WE WILL EXPLAIN JUST AHEAD.
FIRST, EVEN BY THE HIGH
STANDARDS OF 2018, IT WAS A
BIZARRO DAY HERE IN WASHINGTON,
THE PRESIDENT INVITED DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS CHUCK SCHUMER AND
NANCY PELOSI INTO THE
OVAL OFFICE.
A TURN ON THE CAMERAS, AND
INFORMED THEM HE WAS READY TO
SHUT DOWN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IN ORDER TO GET A BORDER WALL.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED NEXT.
>> ONE THING I THINK WE CAN
AGREE ON IS WE SHOULDN'T SHUT
DOWN THE GOVERNMENT OVER A
DISPUTE, AND YOU WANT TO SHUT IT
DOWN.
>> THE LAST TIME, CHUCK, YOU SET
IT DOWN.
>> NO, NO, NO.
>> I DON'T WANT TO DO WHAT YOU
DID.
>> I WILL SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT IF I DON'T GET MY
WALL, NONE OF US --
>> YOU WANT TO PUT --
>> YOU SET IT --
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I WILL SAY?
YES.
IF WE DON'T GET WHAT WE WANT,
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER, WHETHER IT
IS THE REVIEW OR MILITARY, THERE
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO CALL, I
WILL SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT.
>> OKAY.
I DISAGREE.
>> I AM PROUD TO SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT FOR VOTER SECURITY,
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY DON'T WANT
CRIMINALS AND PEOPLE THAT HAVE L
CRIMINALS AND PEOPLE THAT HAVE T
CRIMINALS AND PEOPLE THAT HAVE S
OF PROBLEMS AND DRUGS POURING
INTO OUR COUNTRY.
I WILL TAKE THE MANTLE.
I WILL BE THE ONE TO SHUT IT
DOWN.
I'M NOT GOING TO BLAME YOU FOR
IT.
THE LAST TIME YOU SHUT IT DOWN,
IT DIDN'T WORK.
I WILL TAKE THE MANTLE OF
SHUTTING IT DOWN.
>> Tucker: BODY LANGUAGE ANY
INDICATION, CHUCK SCHUMER HAS
NEVER HATED ANYTHING IN HIS
WHOLE LIFE MORE THAN HE HATED
THAT MOMENT YOU JUST SAW.
WEIRDLY, IN WASHINGTON, THERE IS
ALWAYS A SCRAMBLE TO BLAME THE
OTHER SIDE FOR GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWNS.
THAT IS NOT WHAT HAPPENED TODAY.
YOU JUST HEARD THE PRESIDENT
SAID HE WOULD BE PROUD TO TAKE
OR SPONSOR VILLAGE FOR THE
GOVERNMENT SHUTTING DOWN BECAUSE
A WALL IS TOO IMPORTANT.
>> President Trump: WE NEED
BORDER SECURITY, THE WALL AS
PART OF BORDER SECURITY.
YOU CAN HAVE GOOD BORDER
SECURITY WITHOUT THE WALL.
>> THAT IS A POLITICAL PROMISE.
A BORDER SECURITY IS A WAY TO
HONOR OUR RESPONSIBILITIES.
>> THE EXPERTS THAT YOU CAN DO
BORDER SECURITY WITHOUT A WALL,
WHICH IS WASTEFUL AND DOESN'T
SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: BY THIS POINT IN
THE EXCHANGE, NOT A SINGLE
PERSON WATCHING AT HOME WAS
ATTEMPTED TO CHANGE THE CHANNEL.
IT WAS JUST TOO COMPELLING.
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF APPEARED
TO BE ENJOYING IT.
PELOSI WAS NOT ENJOYING IT.
SHE COMPLAINED OF THE ROOM WAS
WATCHING THEIR ARGUMENT IN REAL
TIME, BUT THE PRESIDENT WOULD
NOT RELENT.
>> WE CAME IN HERE IN GOOD
FAITH, AND WE ARE ENTERING INTO
A DISCUSSION IN THE PUBLIC VIEW.
>> President Trump: IS NOT
BAD, NANCY.
IT'S CALLED TRANSPARENCY.
IT IS A SITUATION WHERE IT IS
NOT EASY FOR HER TO TALK RIGHT
NOW, AND I UNDERSTAND THAT.
I FULLY UNDERSTAND THAT.
WE CAN HAVE A GOOD DISCUSSION,
AND WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE BORDER
SECURITY.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, PLEASE DON'T
CHARACTERIZE THE STRENGTH I
BRING TO THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS IS
ONE BIG VICTORY.
WE >> Tucker: IT WAS AN AMAZING
MOMENT.
THE PRESIDENT AS A BEST WHEN HE
WAS FIGHTING FOR THE PRINCIPLES
HE RAN ON, BUT TWEETING IS NOT
MAKING POLICY AND THREATENING A
SHUTDOWN IS NOT THE SAME AS
SHUTTING DOWN THE GOVERNMENT,
NOR IS GETTING A WALL BUILT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE THAT
THREAD BEFORE.
IN MARCH, SIGNED A SPENDING BILL
WITH NO WALL FUNDING, SAID HE
WOULD NEVER SIGN A BILL LIKE
THAT AGAIN.
IN JULY, HE TWEETED THIS, "I
WOULD BE WILLING TO SHUT DOWN
GOVERNMENT AND THE DEMOCRATS DO
NOT GIVE US THE BOAT FOR BORDER
SECURITY, WHICH INCLUDES A
WALL."
A SEPTEMBER BUDGET SHOWDOWN CAME
AND WENT WITH NO SHUTDOWN AND NO
WALL.
THIS, DECEMBER 2018, IS THE
PRESIDENT'S FINAL CHANCE TO GET
A BORDER WALL, CENTRAL TO HIS
CAMPAIGN IN 2016.
THAT WILL NEVER HAPPEN WHILE
DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
IN THE MEANTIME, RICHARD
GOODSTEIN JOINS US, AN ATTORNEY
THAT ADVISED BILL AND
HILLARY CLINTON.
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM.
GET THE THEATRICS OF IT,
AMAZING, WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER
PELOSI AND SCHUMER KNEW THERE
WERE GOING TO BE CAMERAS THERE.
THAT WILL BECOME CLEAR IN THE
COMING DAYS.
IT IS CLEAR THAT THE DEMOCRATS
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED THE WALL.
BUT THEREFORE A FENCE.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE?
>> THE SIGNATURE PROMISE WAS WE
ARE GOING TO BUILD A WALL AND
MEXICO IS GOING TO PAY FOR IT
GET READY NAFTA DEAL SIGNED, HIS
OPPORTUNITY TO GET MEXICO TO
PAY, AND HE DIDN'T.
CAN WE AT LEAST SUSPEND ANY
BELIEF THAT HE IS GOING TO MAKE
GOOD ON THAT PART OF THE PROMIS
PROMISE?
>> Tucker: I THINK THE REST OF
US ARE INTERESTED, NOT JUST IN
THE RHETORIC, BUT WE HAVE
22 MILLION PEOPLE HERE
ILLEGALLY.
THAT IS A DISASTER.
THE LATEST ESTIMATE IS 22 --
TENS OF MILLIONS HERE ILLEGALLY.
OUR BORDERS ARE NOT SECURE.
DEMOCRATS SAID THEY ARE FOR A
FENCE, BUT AGAINST A WALL PAIRED
PELOSI TOLD US LAST WEEK THE
WALL IS "IMMORAL" BEARD WHAT IS
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A FENCE
AND A WALL?
LIES A FENCE OKAY ON A WALL IS
NOT?
>> I WILL CODE MY QUOTE JOHN
KELLY IN HIS CONFIRMATION
HEARING.
A PHYSICAL BARRIER IN AND OF
ITSELF DOES NOT DO THE JOB, WE
DON'T WILL NOT WANT TO KEEP
PLAYING GOAL LINE DEFENSE
AGAINST PEOPLE OWNING IT FROM
ANOTHER COUNTRY.
AGAIN, CAN WE AGREE WHEN THE
PRESIDENT SAYS "WE ARE STARTING,
WE BUILT A WALL," THAT IS
NONSENSE.
WE HAVE THOSE PROTO-        PROO
WE HAVE THOSE PROTO-        PROY
WE HAVE THOSE PROTO-        PROI
WE HAVE THOSE PROTO-        PROT
WE HAVE THOSE PROTO-        PRON
WE HAVE THOSE PROTO-        PROG
IN THE DESERT.
>> Tucker: WE CAN AGREE WITH
WHAT I HAVE SET A MILLION TIMES
ON THE SHOW COME HE PROMISED TO
BUILD A WALL AND WE SHOULD BUILD
ONE.
WHAT IS HE ASKING FOR NOW, I
AGREE WITH YOU, BUT HE IS ASKING
FOR THE MONEY TO PAY FOR THE
WALL THAT HE PROMISED.
THE PEOPLE WANT, THE PEOPLE
VOTED FOR THAT, 64 MILLION
PEOPLE.
>> MOST PEOPLE VOTED AGAINST
HIM.
>> Tucker: WIRE DEMOCRATS -- I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
OPPOSITION IS.
IT'S WASTEFUL, OKAY, THIS IS A
PARTY THAT SUPPORTS HEADSTART
AFTER 55 YEARS -- WHY DO THEY
SUPPORT A FENCE AND NOT A WALL?
EXPLAIN IT TO ME.
>> WHEN THERE WAS A BILL THAT
PASSED THE SENATE BACK IN 2013,
BOTH FROM ORRIN HATCH, LINDSEY
GRAHAM, MARCO RUBIO, FOR
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM, IT INCLUDED BEEFING UP
BORDER SECURITY.
I DIDN'T CALL FOR A WALL
BECAUSE, AS CHUCK SCHUMER SAID,
THE EXPERTS BELIEVE THE WALL,
LIKE ISRAEL HAD, WOULD IT BE
EFFECTIVE HERE, FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS.
>> Tucker: IS IT IMMORAL?
>> NO.
BECAUSE I THINK THE PEOPLE
COMING INTO ISRAEL ARE BLOWING
PEOPLE UP    UP AND AWAY WAY THE
IMMIGRANTS HERE ARE HELPING PICK
OUR FOOD.
AND THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE.
>> Tucker: SUMMER PICKING
FOOD, SOME IS COMMITTING CRIME.
ISRAEL BUILT THE WALL BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHO IS COMING
OVER FROM THE TERRITORIES
BECAUSE IT'S COUNTRY.
THIS IS OUR COUNTRY, SO IT IS
NOT A MORAL WHEN THEY DO IT, BUT
IT IS IMMORAL WHEN WE DO IT.
OFFENSE IS OKAY BUT A WALL IS
NOT OKAY.
I'M SINCERELY --
>> WHAT IS IMMORAL IS SPENDING
MONEY ON SOMETHING YOU KNOW IS
NOT GOING TO WORK.
THE EXPERTS -- JOHN KELLY WAS UP
FOR DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY, HE SAID THE
WALL WAS NOT GOING TO BE BUILT
FROM SEA TO SHINING SEA.
>> Tucker: HERE IS THE POINT,
WHATEVER WE ARE DOING DOES NOT
WORK.
YOU KNOW AS WELL AS I THAT THE
FEAR WITH THE WALL AS IT WILL
WORK, AND WILL PREVENT VOTERS
FROM COMING OVER FROM
LATIN AMERICA TO BOLSTER THE
FORTUNES OF A PARTY THAT ACTUAL
AMERICANS DON'T REALLY LIKE THAT
MUCH, WHICH IS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> EVEN THOUGH THE DEMOCRATS --
IT WOULD HAVE PASSED THE HOUSE,
INCIDENTALLY, 15 REPUBLICAN
VOTES IN THE SENATE, CALLED FOR
A VERY PROTRACTED.
LACK OF TIME BEFORE PEOPLE WHO
WERE ALREADY HERE TO GET
CITIZENSHIP.
>> Tucker: NORMAL PEOPLE ARE
LIKE, WE DON'T HAVE CONTROL OF
OUR BORDERS.
A WALL IS NOT THE WHOLE ANSWER.
>> DONALD TRUMP BRAGS ABOUT THE
FACT, ALL THESE PEOPLE BEING
STOPPED.
HAS IT WORKED OR NOT WORKED?
>> Tucker: HERE TO DEFEND THE
COUNTRY, NOT A POLITICIAN.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS ACTUALLY
SPIKING RIGHT NOW.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF REASONS
FOR THAT.
THE FACT REMAINS THAT IT IS
TRUE, AND IT IS BAD FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
WE'VE NEVER TRIED A WALL.
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS ARE AGAINST
A WALL BECAUSE THEY ARE FOR A
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
I GET IT.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
ARGUMENT AGAINST A WALL IS.
ALL THE THINGS WE SPEND MONEY
ON, WHY NOT TRY THE WALL?
"NO, THAT IS IMMORAL," WHY?
>> IT IS IMPRACTICAL.
I'M NOT THE EXPERT, NOR ARE YOU,
BUT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SAY IT IS
IMPRACTICAL.
EVE VERIFICATION, GETTING
EMPLOYERS NOT TO HIRE PEOPLE WHO
ARE HERE ILLEGALLY.
THAT WOULD BE EFFECTIVE.
>> Tucker: DEMOCRATS ARE
OPPOSED TO UNIVERSAL E-VERIFY.
THERE IS NO SUPPORT FOR THAT,
DONORS MAKE MONEY FOR UNDER
CUTTING AMERICAN WAGES.
>> IN THE BILL THAT PASSED WITH
EVERY DEMOCRAT IN THE SENATE IN
2013 AND WOULD HAVE PASSED THE
HOUSE --
>> Tucker: WE ARE GOING TO
PUNISH EMPLOYERS IF THEY HOW
YOUR ILLEGALS HERE JUST FOR
THAT?
NO, SHE IS AGAINST THAT.
>> NANCY PELOSI HAS SAID FROM
THE START, BACK THEN, IF YOU
BRING UP THAT BILL THAT PASSED
THE SENATE.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE ALL
AGAINST IT.
CAN YOU SEE THE FRUSTRATION
WHERE WE FUND OTHER COUNTRIES'
BORDER WALLS AND CALL THEM
VIRTUOUS, AMERICANS ARE LIKE, WE
WANT TO PROTECT OUR OWN COUNTRY
AND SHUT UP RACIST, YOU ARE
IMMORAL, DO YOU SEE THE PROBLEM?
SPEED WITHOUT BE A PROBLEM FOR
IT IS TRUE.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO BEEF UP
SECURITY ALONG THE BORDER.
IT IS A MYTH, I KNOW THAT PLACE
IS A BASE, IT HAPPENS NOT TO BE
TRUE.
>> Tucker: HOW DID WE GET
ILLEGALS HERE THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
PROTECTING?
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN, THEREFORE
LIMITING RELATION, DULL.
>> OBAMA WAS CRITICIZED BY THE
HISPANIC COMMUNITY FOR
DEPORTING --
>> Tucker: THEY ARE HISPANIC
PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR TRUMP COME
ALL KIND OF DIFFERENT VIEWS.
JUST BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE ONE
ETHNICITY DOESN'T MEAN THEY'LL
HAVE THE SAME VIEWS, YOU KNOW
WHAT I MEAN?
>> OF COURSE, THAT IS TRUE OF
EVERY.
OBAMA DEPORTING MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE, THE NOTION THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE UNWILLING TO
DEPORT PEOPLE --
>> Tucker: I SEE NANCY PELOSI
TELLING ME I AM IMMORAL FOR
WANTING TO FIX IT.
>> I THINK, GIVE HER A CHANCE TO
GET A BILL PASSED IN THE HOUSE,
WE WILL SEE.
>> Tucker: RICHARD, GOOD
SEEING YOU.
GOOGLE CEO CAME TO CAPITOL HILL
TODAY, CONGRESS ASKED HIM A LOT
OF QUESTIONS.